okay time for the last set of audience
questions from the last Friday show
actually the last show really the last
new show of 2018 we will be off on
Monday and Tuesday New Year's Eve New
Year's Day just a reminder okay question
number one important question relevant
question too many people in our audience
David will Donald Trump survive 2019
okay so I I'm guessing you mean not as
an individual not will Trump be alive at
the end of 2019 although me maybe that
is what this person means I think the
answer is probably yes will Donald Trump
as president survive 2019 here's the
thing about that question I can imagine
all sorts of paths to Donald Trump not
being president on January 1 2020
impeachment if Republicans say we can't
do this anymore and if Democrats start
impeachment proceedings Republicans in
the Senate saying it's got to end it
just has to end at this point it's too
much of a political liability for us
it's too much of a liability for the
country a negotiated resignation with
robert muller where Moeller ghost to
trump and says it's bad here's what we
have we would recommend indictment even
though the courts would have to figure
out whether we can indict a sitting
president but we would be willing to
negotiate your resignation from the
presidency instead of bringing these
charges recommending this indictment we
have this sort of long list but in the
end I believe that Donald Trump will
survive as president from a 20-19 into
2020 mostly because it's really hard to
remove a president and it should be but
beyond that for political reasons unless
there is absolutely no other way out
Republicans aren't going to move to
remove Trump and therefore Donald Trump
is not going to feel the pressure that
he otherwise might if if he indeed has
done things for which he should no
longer be president the other thing you
have to remember is that this could end
up being really determined
or by I guess what we would call non
criminal factors than criminal factors
there's every indication that every
aspect of Donald Trump's life including
both the campaign and the presidency are
riddled with some forms of criminality
quid pro quos allowing foreign countries
to dictate our foreign policy money
laundering related to the campaign
itself accepting things of value both
during the campaign and during the
presidency from foreign power although
we don't even have to debate any of that
stuff because ultimately I believe that
Donald Trump's survival as president
from 2019 into 2020 is going to be
determined how other things are going in
other words do Republicans believe that
they can be re-elected if they continue
to allow the Trump presidency to
continue if they think that they can be
re-elected then they will allow the
Trump presidency to continue because
there is risk of course with turning on
the president from your own party how is
the economy doing all of these other
factors are going to determine how
tolerant Republicans are willing to be
in terms of keeping a man that is
effectively a criminal in the White
House overall I think it's about two to
one that Trump survives if you look at
the betting websites where you can
actually bet on whether Donald Trump's
presidency survives 2019 it's roughly
around that and I think that that tells
us the most likely scenario is January 1
2020 Trump is President of the United
States once it is 2020 then we will be
dealing with the 2020 election and that
is the subject of the next question